when the World Cup comes around there's
a lot of pressure on this guy Harry Kane
the England football captain but in
addition to his day job can he also save
that beleaguered Temple of consumerism
the shopping mall
it may seem an unlikely match-up but
he's involved in a big bet on future of
shopping of which more later let's start
with the basics the business model for
shopping malls used to be pretty
straightforward you would offer cheap
rent to a department store like
Nordstrom or Macy's in the US or John
Lewis and Debenhams in the UK and they
would become what is known as an anchor
tenant the idea is that they would bring
in Choppers from miles around which
would then make it easier to attract
smaller shops to fill the spots around
it that would fill out your more
e-commerce changed all that if you could
buy something online that would appear
on your doorstep a day or two later it
was suddenly less appealing to drive
miles to an out of town shopping center
and department stores in particular
suffered many of them closed down that
creates a problem for landlords who all
of a sudden didn't have an anchor tenant
which is where Harry Kane comes in he's
an investor in Toca social which is part
of a new wave of businesses that are
booming as we emerge from the covid-19
pandemic I like to kind of maybe go
newer companies who maybe have a bigger
Grove and bigger chance to expand
they're known as experiential
entertainment or entertainment sometimes
bars that incorporate another activity
such as mini golf in the case of putt
Shack darts in the case of Flight Club
table tennis when it comes to bounce and
football soccer in the case of Toca
social so experiential entertainment
economy has exploded in recent years and
this is a trend we expect to accelerate
we're seeing a kind of remarkable
increase in people wanting to do more of
their nights out Beyond just eating and
drinking and many people or many
companies have already applied the
experiential entertainment model very
successfully to different sports most
notably golf but also darts and and
others players get little booth where
they aim to hit moving Targets on the
screen with a football you can have a
beer and some chicken wings while your
mates are playing this isn't the bowling
alley of your grandparents there's all
sorts of technical Wizardry the good
news for shopping malls and their
landlords is that these sort of spots
attract families and kids during the day
and the social crowd out for a drink in
the evening department stores are always
seen as as the anchors of of the
shopping centers I think to be to be
frank they hadn't anchored them in the
way they originally intended for quite a
while these are not new Spaces by and
large I think there are some new
Concepts and there are new ways they're
being managed I think the key thing is
that is that it now has a wider reach I
think it's got a broader demographic I
think it's better engaged with the local
customer in many cases locations that
used to be occupied by department stores
are now being offered to these
experiential entertainment firms that
also means they're getting some of the
same deals on the rent in the case of
putt Shack the setup costs are about
eight million dollars and in many cases
landlords are fronting as much as
two-thirds of that to entice them in it
appears to pay off consumers played a
million games of mini golf in putt
Shack's first year at its location in
West London and they take up a pretty
big footprint too 30 to 40 000 square
feet not quite as big as the 70 000
square feet of a department store but
still bigger than a lot of other shops
many of these concepts are originating
in the UK before they cross the pond to
the US part Shack which just raised 150
million dollars from BlackRock was
founded by Stephen and Dave Joseph the
same Brothers Who Sold Topgolf to
Callaway for two billion dollars just a
few years ago the firm behind bounce and
Flight Club is based in London and just
raised an additional 35 million dollars
in funding Harry Kane invested in Toca
social in January he's hoping that the
business helps pay some of the bills
when he ultimately gets around to
retiring the company aims to add as many
as 50 sites in the UK and expand
globally I feel like this would grow as
the years go on and there will be tweets
that made along the way that will
improve it and you know maybe by the
time I'm retired it'll be in a really
fantastic place and and I can just maybe
enjoy playing football for fun instead
of professionally Harry Kane can't save
the shopping mall on his own nor can
Toca social but landlords certainly we
hope that these sort of spots can give
them a new lease of life